[Music]
this is Parker Ranch
with 130 000 sprawling Green Acres and
over 10 000 cows it's one of America's
oldest and largest cattle ranches
but it's not located in Montana Nebraska
or Texas
instead it's nestled on the world's most
isolated populace archipelago Hawaii
despite this seclusion Parker Ranch has
one huge Advantage it's American
these beach-going bovines are exempt
from tariffs import quotas and foreign
Health certifications
the company has direct domestic access
to the world's number one consumer of
beef
the country that comprises just four
percent of the global population but
eats 21 of its cows
at least this should be an advantage
the United States should benefit from
this convergence of domestic supply and
demand one far from unique to beef
take for instance oil Americans may be
its most notoriously gluttonous
consumers but forget the Middle East the
U.S produces nearly as much as it uses
18 versus 19 million barrels a day
respectively
to a remarkable extent America has what
it needs
for this it has not only its size to
thank but also its unmatched economic
and Geographic diversity
from the cold Continental Northeast to
the hot bone dry Southwest it spans the
whole climatic Spectrum
now throw in Honolulu and Fairbanks and
America truly has everything
in addition to being blessed with many
of the precise inputs it requires it's
also lucky enough to have 95 000 miles
of Coastline with which to connect them
though we may take it for granted the
result is the best of both worlds
a massive diverse and well-endowed land
mass yet because of its abundant
waterways the kind of cheap efficient
transport usually reserved for much
denser places
strangely you won't find as much
evidence of this Good Fortune as its
geography would suggest
for a country capable of being so
self-sufficient it sources a
surprisingly small share of its trade
internally
despite for example its almost perfect
symmetry of oil production and
consumption nearly 50 percent is shipped
away overseas and the same amount
imported from abroad
Pig farmers in North Carolina buy their
soybeans not from Iowa but Brazil
and Maryland it's rock salt not from
Louisiana a thousand miles away but
chilly over five
of course there are many reasons to ship
the same product from further away some
obvious and some not global trade is an
intricate web of nested decisions and
fluctuating trade-offs
but unlike say foreign subsidies which
no doubt diminish American
competitiveness one reason is entirely
self-inflicted
the first clue that something strange is
happening something beyond the normal
inscrutable quirks of shipping lies in
this graph
the United States ships about 50 percent
more cargo by rail today than in 1960.
we have more oil pipelines more trucks
and far more international shipping
lanes
in fact every major type of
Transportation has seen growth in the
last half century how could they Notch
when the population doubled
except curiously one
American ships move less cargo
domestically today than they did 60
years ago when a gallon of gas cost 31
cents and the first episode of The
Flintstones aired on television
this is clearly not the inevitable
outcome of Market forces
this is the result of an arbitrary
inefficient outdated and unnecessary
impediment to the U.S economy
one reason America fails to take full
advantage of its fantastic geography is
a single clause in a 103 year old law
called The Jones Act
it states that any ship moving goods
between two American ports must be one
built in the United States two crude by
U.S citizens three owned by U.S citizens
and four registered in the U.S
foreign ships can still for example
bring goods from Hong Kong to Seattle in
fact they do this every day they can
even then proceed to Los Angeles before
returning to Asia
what they can't do is pick anything up
in Seattle and bring it to LA
once something arrives on America's
Shores it can legally no longer be
touched by the very same foreign boat
that brought it
many countries have laws of this variety
but none are nearly as strict as America
which had to negotiate for itself a
special exception to free trade rules
when joining the World Trade
Organization
not a great look for the self-described
champion of open markets
the reason any of this matters is that
as will surprise exactly no one American
labor is not cheap
American ships are therefore more
expensive to build operate and maintain
now you might be thinking of course
American Architects are also more
expensive so are its nurses and teachers
that boats are too may not sound all
that scandalous
and normally you'd be right but 100
million dollar boats are not normal
products they're the textbook example of
economies of scale
building a hundred ships in other words
is astronomically cheaper per unit than
building 50.
still it would be one thing if we were
talking about 50 or even 25. but once
you get down to the single digits the
cost per ship skyrockets to the point of
being almost comical what would it cost
to build just two f-35s
that's about how many ocean-going cargo
carrying ships America builds in a
typical year
American ships cost more so fewer are
built and because fewer are built they
cost more
you can watch this feedback cycle play
out over the last century in 1920
american-built ships were 20 percent
more expensive
that Rose to 50 by the 30s 200 percent
by the 50s 300 by the 90s and 500
percent today
that mind you is before a boat is even
christened once it sees the light of day
operating costs are 2.7 Times Higher
according to the U.S Maritime
Administration
another source found a difference of six
American ships aren't just more
expensive they're not just way more
expensive they're so expensive that they
exist in an entirely separate category
truly because U.S ships cost five times
more than their foreign counterparts
they simply can't compete
therefore unless subsidized they're
approximately never used for foreign
trade
there's the American Fleet and there's
the rest of the world
[Music]
shipping anything domestically by water
is a very last resort
you'd sooner hire a donkey to carry your
cargo Overland from Seattle to Boston
than use a boat
of course the Jones Act only applies to
boats U.S airlines can buy from Airbus
and truckers from Volvo
you can probably see where this is going
since the Jones Act was passed in 1920
America has seen an unmistakable shift
from Mirror time to every other form of
Transport as we saw in this graph from
earlier
the Jones Act is by no means the only
reason the U.S also built an entire
interstate highway system in the interim
but there's no doubt in its role
today just two percent of American
Freight Travels by sea in Europe where
by the way there are also highways that
number is 40 percent
even Hawaiian cows have opted for air
travel live calves are driven from the
Serene Northern tip of the big island to
Kona International Airport and flown on
747s to California
in the end Americans collectively pay
for every pound of cargo diverted from
ship to airplane truck or train in the
form of traffic jams and carbon
emissions
no mode of Transport generates fewer
greenhouse gas emissions than boats
and while a cargo ship may be slower
than a truck it's far more cost
effective
rivers and oceans are relatively green
maintenance-free infinite Lane highways
we also pay in the form of lost Revenue
however close an American supplier and
however far its foreign competitor the
latter is almost always cheaper when
ocean transport is required
to use a highly imperfect analogy the
Jones Act is a bit like Congress
mandating that the left half of every
road suddenly be abandoned not to make
room for some urbanist Utopia this is
still the United States of America we're
talking about
are 4 million miles of asphalt wouldn't
be converted into bicycle or pedestrian
paths they would just sit there taking
up space
at first given the lack of public
transit Alternatives the loss of half
our roads would slow down everyone's
commute
but over time knowing America's
addiction to cars we'd extend our
freeways to compensate for the Lost left
half
strange and arbitrary though this rule
Transportation wouldn't grind to a halt
forever we'd adapt but at an enormous
environmental social and financial cost
the Jones act hasn't doomed America to
financial ruin for most of the country
it's merely diverted cargo to less
efficient more damaging modes of
transport
but some places don't have this luxury
there are no roads or trains connecting
Hawaii Puerto Rico or Guam to the
mainland these are captive markets
unable to extend their highways in the
previous analogy these places are stuck
with what they've got
Hawaii Puerto Rico and Alaska
collectively make up just 1.6 percent of
the U.S population but they ship 35
percent of all domestic ocean-going
tonnage they have to
and what happens in captive markets with
little or no competition
price gouging and price fixing
two companies tote and Crawley control
more than 80 percent of the U.S Mainland
to Puerto Rico Market
Alaska is subject to a tote and Matson
duopoly
in Hawaii and Guam are no different
it should be no surprise therefore that
in 2011 two Jones act carriers pled
guilty to criminal price fixing
[Music]
now lobbyists are quick to point out
that we really have no idea how much
this law hinders the U.S economy
and they're right the sheer complexity
of global Shipping makes it nearly
impossible to honestly and accurately
disentangle the effects of a single law
anyone claiming to have such an estimate
that fully accounts for U.S labor and
tax laws which would likely still apply
even if the Jones act were repealed is
either delusional or openly admits to
much uncertainty but whether the total
cost is 64 billion dollars as the oecd
estimates or even just 10 percent of
that don't mistake our inability to
precisely quantify the cost with the
lack of a cost
after all there's plenty of evidence
take a look for instance at where Puerto
Rico gets its natural gas compared to
the Dominican Republic
despite being just 130 miles apart the
difference is Stark
Puerto Rico a U.S territory gets zero
percent of its LNG from the U.S while
its neighbor gets 65 percent
because of the Jones act Puerto Ricans
effectively pay more for American
Products than do foreign countries
so while the lower 48 have largely
abandoned domestic shipping entirely
these distant territories have been
forced into a battle with their own
government to find and exploit loopholes
in fact the Jones act itself was a
defensive attack against earlier
workarounds
before its passage in 1920 someone in
Seattle could ship their goods 140 miles
by truck to Vancouver Canada then the
other 1600 miles to Anchorage by
Canadian flagged ship
alaskans benefited from this foreign
competition
unfortunately for them they wouldn't get
the right to vote until Alaska became a
state 40 years later
in the meantime the Pacific steamship
company based in Washington which did
have a vote seized this window of
opportunity
it lobbied Senator Wesley Jones to close
this loophole by inserting a clause into
the Merchant Marine Act
that Clause now called The Jones act
specified not only cargo transported by
water but by water or by land and water
humorously it simultaneously opened a
new loophole
the journey from Seattle to Vancouver
could no longer be made by truck but it
could be made by Canadian Train
needless to say things have only gotten
more complex in the past hundred years
the Jones act has slowly transformed
into a strange and arbitrary swiss
cheese Patchwork of rules
for example what does it mean for a
public company to be American in 2023
the answer apparently is that 75 percent
of its shareholders must be U.S citizens
that is unless the CEO of the foreign
owner pinky promises not to interfere
with American interests in which case
All Is Forgiven
then there's the question of what
exactly counts as American built
the answer is that the Coast Guard will
Seize Your Ship if it has a foreign
built hole but not if it has a foreign
build engine
the propeller Machinery consoles wiring
and piping can be foreign but no more
than 1.5 percent of the steel weight of
the superstructure makes sense
if not the US government has prepared
for you a 29-page PDF defining terms
like point and transportation often in
strange and unexpected ways
one of the most important definitions
depends on the precise interpretation of
new and different
recall that you cannot legally ship your
Hawaiian cows on a foreign ship to
Vancouver and then Seattle by truck
except you can if your product is
manufactured into something quote new
and different during its foreign Pit
Stop
luckily for Parker Ranch the U.S
government considers cows in various
stages of growth as different products
Cavs versus Slaughter cows for instance
Parker Ranch could therefore raise its
calves for 30 days until they reached
about 400 pounds and then ship them to
Vancouver where they were fattened up to
800 or a thousand pounds
at some unknown point during this
process they transform in the eyes of
the law into new and different products
enabling their shipment down to Sumas
Washington
but let's say you're the world's most
patriotic Hawaiian cowboy
even if you're willing to pay any price
to use american-built ships you're going
to run into a new problem there aren't
any
which gets to the heart of the issue
supporters of the Jones act argue it
does serve a genuine purpose that it's
not nearly as arbitrary as the road
analogy would suggest
this is true
the US military was stretched to its
limits during the first World War
the Jones Act was intended to prevent
this from happening again to guarantee a
sizable U.S Fleet in times of need
and at first glance it appears to have
worked in total there are about forty
thousand U.S flagged vessels
but this is highly misleading
the vast majority of those are barges
tugboats and other small ships mainly
used on the Mississippi and other Inland
Rivers
barges are great but they're far from
ideal replacements for faster larger
more reliable and economical ocean-going
ships like tankers
they're also not the kind of ship the
Navy would need during a war
what it would need are large ocean-going
ships of which there are only about 100
left
that's right 100 for the entire United
States
and because American repairs are so
expensive those 100 ships are old
outdated and in some cases downright
dangerous
one sank in a hurricane in 2015. since
it was 40 years old it was built without
modern lifeboats
all of this is to say there just aren't
very many American ships
typically cows are transported by
specialized livestock carriers
but there isn't a single one in the
whole us of a
instead Hawaiian ranchers had to invent
an entirely new method what they call
cow tainers to get their cattle on
standard cargo ships
neither is there a single LNG tanker or
asphalt carrier or cement carrier they
just don't exist
now the most reasonable supporters of
the Jones act will concede to these
costs
sure the situation is less than ideal
they might say but National Security is
simply too important
and while the U.S Fleet is indeed small
at least it exists at all
there's some Merit to this argument the
free market is certainly not some sacred
force of nature we ought never disobey
what matters is simply whether the
benefits outweigh the costs
so is everything we've talked about
worth the chance that if America is
involved in a war and if the Navy runs
low and if they're available and useful
it can commandeer 100 slow inefficient
and outdated commercial ships
even if your answer is yes a better
question is if those are indeed our
goals is there a better way to achieve
them
in fact the United States already has a
stockpile of militarily useful ships on
reserve
no actually in typical U.S military
fashion it has three the ready Reserve
Force Maritime security program and
sealift command
meanwhile two of the three most prolific
shipbuilding nations are close American
Allies
we know these countries would sell the
US military the ships it needs because
well they do
amusingly most of the ready Reserve four
ships were built internationally
in other words foreign ships are
apparently good enough for the U.S
military but when it comes to
non-military purely commercial ships
we're told to think about National
Security
in case there was any doubt this fact
exposes the truth about the Jones act it
originated as an opportunistic way for
Senator Wesley Jones to win support from
Washington voters and it continues to
serve the same protectionist purpose
today
a small handful of powerful unions and
their lobbyists have essentially held
America's Incredible Geographic
potential hostage
it works because most of us don't know
or think about the Jones Act
we never see its costs directly
it thrives like many bad policies on our
lack of awareness
one of the best ways to increase
awareness is by making videos like this
one that's why I made this class on
today's sponsor skillshare showing you
step by step how I make my thumbnails
and going behind the scenes on how I
make these videos you can also find
courses from MKBHD thomasfrank and many
of your other favorite channels
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of courses on
everything from graphic design to
project management and programming
what's great about skillshare is that
you get access to every course on the
platform with a single subscription once
you sign up you're motivated to learn
more to make the most of your membership
an annual subscription costs less than
10 bucks a month and the first 1000
people to join by clicking the link on
screen now get a one month free trial
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video